And the correct answer is this: we'll see an error message, but the quote
messes up our HTML,
And let's see that happen, together.
We said the quote was going to mess up our HTML--
let's submit the form
and here we go.
We've got our error message, but the string that I answered
was: bar">what
and "what" appeared outside of our text box.
Now it's not too tricky to see why this happened.
What happened was this string here--
this Python string--doesn't know it's HTML
and when we entered in a quote
in our string, Python substituted a quote in the middle of here
and then I also put an angle bracket in,
and that closed the tag.
And then the other string that I typed appeared outside here.